what's this one now
the dance of dragons a true telling by
grand master monkey
well that sounds like a proper story
it's the story of the fight between
ronira targaryen and the halfway dragon
for control of the seven kingdoms
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
brothers fought brothers
dragon sport dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead
and it was the disaster of the targaryen
as well they never truly recovered
is that a dance it's just what they call
it
and it makes sense i think it's
permitted
[Music]
renera targaryen was murdered by her
brother or
rather his dragon it ate her while her
son
watched
you had to choose
between
who would you chose
i wouldn't have chosen either saw the
choosing size that made everything so
horrible
sometimes a person has to choose